hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 64 en donde hablaremos
del equilibrio químico y me gustaría
empezar con una demostración aquí
solamente pasa en agua de un jarrón a
otro eso representa a los reactivos y a
los productos y observen que conforme
pasa en el agua de izquierda a derecha
es decir del lado de los reactivos al de
los productos usa en un vaso grande pero
al pasar agua del lado de los productos
al de los reactivos el vaso es pequeño
en total tardan como 7 minutos en hacer
esto así que voy a acelerarlo un poco
entonces los reactivos se convierten en
productos y un poco de esos productos se
convierten nuevamente en reactivos y
podríamos pensar que el lado izquierdo
quedará vacío pero en realidad no
podemos sacar toda el agua más bien el
sistema alcanza el equilibrio aún cuando
seguimos moviendo agua de un lado a otro
en algún punto la cantidad de agua
que se mueve será la misma ahí es cuando
alcanzamos el equilibrio entonces en una
reacción reversible los reactivos se
convierten en productos y los productos
en reactivos y con el tiempo alcanzan el
equilibrio en donde los reactivos y los
productos reaccionan a la misma
velocidad y para medir todo esto usamos
la constante de equilibrio que es igual
a la concentración de los productos
entre la concentración de los reactivos
y miren en el vídeo anterior aprendimos
que antes de alcanzar acá la constante
de equilibrio podemos calcular que que
es lo mismo pero se calcula antes de
llegar al equilibrio entonces si
comparamos los valores de cubo y acá
podemos predecir lo que está sucediendo
en la reacción y bueno como ejemplo
veamos el proceso deja ver que es un
proceso en el que podemos obtener
amoniaco a partir de nitrógeno gaseoso e
hidrógeno gaseoso es una reacción
reversible
si analizamos las concentraciones en el
tiempo para este proceso obtenemos una
gráfica como ésta y miren al principio
tenemos más reactivos que productos de
hecho al principio tenemos cero
productos hasta que en algún momento de
la reacción se alcanza el equilibrio es
decir se alcanza ese punto en el que las
concentraciones se mantienen constantes
con el tiempo ese sería nuestro punto de
equilibrio y ahora les mostraré esta
gráfica en donde analizamos la relación
de la reacción directa con la reacción
inversa y miren obtenemos una gráfica
como ésta pero porque las dos cosas se
une bueno porque si recuerdan la
demostración la cantidad de agua que se
movía de izquierda a derecha es decir en
la reacción directa igualada a la
cantidad que regresaba es decir a la
reacción inversa y ahí es cuando
alcanzamos el equilibrio
y ahora me gustaría enseñarles cómo
calculé los valores de acá y que miren
para empezar
simplemente veamos cuál es el número de
reactivos y de productos que tenemos al
equilibrio pero como lo calculé bueno
simplemente tomé la relación de
productos y reactivos que tantos
productos tenemos aquí supongamos que
tenemos 2 y cuántos reactivos 4 por lo
tanto el valor de cap para este caso es
0.5 y si ahora nos colocamos un poco
antes ocurre lo mismo y aquí también acá
es igual a 0.5 así que la constante de
equilibrio que se mantiene igual siempre
y cuando nos encontremos al equilibrio
pero analicemos lo que pasa antes de eso
ahora calculemos q que lo podemos
calcular antes de alcanzar el equilibrio
por ejemplo en este punto tenemos
aproximadamente 0.5 de productos y 5 de
reactivos así que obtenemos un valor
0.1 y si nos movemos al inicio el valor
de q es igual a 0 porque tenemos 0
productos qué pasa si el valor de q es
menor a k bueno eso significa que la
reacción se moverá hacia la derecha es
decir si el valor de q es menor a k
la reacción tenderá hacia los productos
y si analizamos una reacción como está
aquí tenemos nuevamente el valor de k
que será constante mientras la
concentración de reactivos y de
productos no cambie pero para calcular q
observen que los reactivos y los
productos son iguales por lo tanto el
valor de q es igual a 1 y qué me dicen
aquí aquí será igual a 5 así que en este
caso nuestros valores de q son mayores
al valor de k por lo tanto la reacción
se moverá hacia la izquierda es decir
hacia los reactivos ahora supongamos que
nos dan estos valores de q
y queremos saber si la reacción se
moverá hacia la izquierda o hacia la
derecha bueno muchas veces puede ser
confuso pero simplemente pongan los
valores de kubica en una recta numérica
y recuerden que es a donde queremos
llegar y q es en dónde nos encontramos
así que en este caso tenemos que
movernos hacia la izquierda tenemos que
movernos desde los productos hacia los
reactivos y ahora veamos cómo avanza
cada uno de los compuestos que
participan en esta reacción en este caso
empezamos con una concentración alta de
hidrógeno gaseoso y nada de amoniaco
pero con el tiempo se alcanza el
equilibrio y las concentraciones se
mantienen constantes y aunque
empezáramos con concentraciones
diferentes nuevamente se alcanzará el
equilibrio entonces una vez que las
concentraciones se mantienen constantes
y no cambian con el tiempo hemos
alcanzado el equilibrio
y bueno cuando les mostré el cálculo de
k les oculte la complejidad para
mantenerlo sencillo les dije que solo
tenemos que dividir los productos entre
los reactivos pero en realidad para
conocer el valor de k tenemos que
basarnos en los compuestos de la
reacción química reversible miren como
una forma general así es como se expresa
acá supongamos que tenemos una reacción
en la que estos son nuestros reactivos
bueno las letras a yb e minúscula
representan los moles del compuesto a y
b respectivamente y esta es la forma en
la que lo escribimos entonces si
empezamos con los productos recuerden
los productos van arriba tenemos la
concentración de ce que sería este
compuesto elevado a esta potencia que
corresponde a esta así y eso por la
concentración de d mayúscula elevada a d
minúscula veamos un ejemplo de esto tal
vez así sea más fácil
y esta es nuestra reacción como
podríamos escribir la ecuación para la
constante de equilibrio usando esto como
referencia vamos a poner los productos
arriba y los reactivos abajo y nos queda
esto la concentración de nitrógeno
gaseoso por la concentración de agua al
cuadrado porque aquí tenemos dos moles
de agua y si analizamos los reactivos
tenemos la concentración de no2 por la
concentración de hidrógeno gaseoso
también al cuadrado ok y si ahora les
dieran un problema como este ya saben
cómo queda la constante de equilibrio
tal vez quieran pausar el vídeo para
intentarlo
ok esta es la respuesta es un poco
diferente a la anterior porque solo
tenemos un producto por eso sólo tenemos
un compuesto en el numerador entonces
tenemos la concentración de amoniaco al
cuadrado el hidrógeno está elevado al
cubo y el nitrógeno está elevado
la primera potencia ahora quiero
enseñarles cómo se calcula acá
estas son las concentraciones molares al
equilibrio pero primero necesitamos
escribir la ecuación que para este caso
ya vimos que acá es igual a la
concentración de amoniaco al cuadrado
entre la concentración de nitrógeno por
la concentración de hidrógeno al cubo
entonces ahora simplemente sustituimos
los valores y al simplificar nos queda
0.0 602 así es cómo calculamos que ahora
analicemos nuestra tabla y si la tabla y
se nos muestra las concentraciones al
inicio en el cambio y al equilibrio
entonces si tenemos esta reacción
reversible podemos calcular el valor de
q y como lo calculamos bueno en este
caso es igual a la concentración de agua
al cuadrado porque aquí tenemos dos
moles por la concentración de nitrógeno
y eso será fácil porque al inicio los
dos
son igual a 0 entonces al sustituir
todos los valores nos queda que q es
igual a 0 eso es lo que tenemos al
inicio pero podrían calcular lo que
sucede al equilibrio si les doy las
concentraciones molares pues pasa lo
mismo acá es igual a todo eso y si
sustituimos los valores y hacemos las
multiplicaciones obtenemos 650 ok
entonces una vez que conocemos q y acá
podemos saber hacia dónde se va la
reacción es decir se moverá hacia la
derecha o hacia la izquierda eso es muy
fácil como q es menor acá
la reacción se moverá hacia la derecha
transformaremos los reactivos en
productos y miren también podemos llenar
el resto de nuestra tabla para conocer
las concentraciones en el cambio si esto
es 0.1 y esto es 0 punto 0 62
simplemente los restamos y nos queda
menos 0.03
8 así es como calculamos las
concentraciones en el cambio y observen
que hay un patrón muy interesante si
observamos todos estos valores podemos
ver que son iguales aún cuando tengan un
signo negativo o positivo y miren son
iguales porque los coeficientes es decir
los moles también son iguales entonces
aquí lo que descubrimos es la este
geometría porque además si analizamos
esto podemos ver que agregamos la mitad
de nitrógeno gaseoso de lo que agregamos
de agua porque aquí sólo tenemos un mol
así que la este geometría nos guía para
conocer las concentraciones en la
segunda fila de la tabla y entonces
primero calculen que después calculen
acá y finalmente podrán saber qué es lo
que ocurre en el cambio pero ahora este
también es un problema muy común
supongamos que solo nos dan las
concentraciones iniciales cv y acá y
tenemos que descubrir el resto de la
tabla
cómo hacemos eso bueno lo primero que
podemos ver es que q es menor acá
la reacción se moverá hacia la derecha o
hacia la izquierda claro sabemos que se
moverá hacia la derecha así que podemos
llenar esos espacios con variables lo
que yo hago es restar una cierta
concentración x y aquí ponemos 2x porque
tenemos dos moles de esto y aquí sólo
tenemos un molde estos entonces la
relación es 2 a 1 y a 1 y miren aquí
tenemos signo negativo y aquí positivo
porque estamos restando la concentración
de los reactivos ya que nuestra reacción
se mueve de izquierda a derecha por eso
sabemos que estos valores son negativos
ok
todavía no sabemos a qué es igual x pero
como conocemos acá que es igual a 16 y
sólo tenemos una incógnita podemos
calcular eso
lo hacemos bueno primero necesitamos
escribir la ecuación de la constante de
equilibrio que en este caso es igual a
la concentración de h y al cuadrado
porque tenemos dos moles y después
simplemente sustituimos los valores
arriba sustituimos 2x y abajo ponemos
las concentraciones de los reactivos
pero como las dos son iguales podemos
simplemente elevar al cuadrado ahora tal
vez se espanten en este punto porque
tenemos 16 igual a en realidad es muy
fácil observen que estamos elevando al
cuadrado tanto lo que tenemos en el
numerador como en el denominador así que
podemos sacar la raíz cuadrada en ambos
lados de la igualdad y nos queda esto y
así podemos calcular x y obtenemos que x
es igual a cero punto 666 y ahora
simplemente sustituimos el valor de x en
nuestra tabla dice y así nos quedan
estos valores entonces con
siendo la constante de equilibrio
podemos calcular el resto de la tabla lo
aprendieron ya pueden leer gráficas como
esta para saber si basándonos en la
concentración de los productos y de los
reactivos alcanzamos el equilibrio y
aprendieron hacia dónde se mueve la
reacción o pueden usar los datos para
predecir la dirección de una reacción
izquierda a derecha o derecha a
izquierda para alcanzar el equilibrio y
ya pueden calcular acá o determinar las
concentraciones al equilibrio si nos dan
acá espero que les ayude